[Música]
ele começou a contar uma história que
ouvi de um amigo na semana passada a
história de três velejadores estava
viajando em alto mar
um era o tenista voltou otimista e o
terceiro realista estava velejando pelo
alto mar e de repente o vento parou
estavam parados ali eu penso nisso falou
pronto morri já era se entregou e tentou
foi esperar morrer aqui
o time foi não tenho certeza que vai dar
certo a gente vai pra lá eu estava indo
pra lá vou continuar indo que tenho
certeza que vai dar certo aqui vou
continuar com a minha vela montada pela
revista falou não pára aí que está
acontecendo aqui ele parou e observou
não tem vento pra ir pra lá tem chance
de morrer se eu ficar aqui como eu saio
daqui com fãs
ele começou a observar começou a
observar o mar começou a observar o
vento eo evento não tinha acabado antes
desaparecidos já tinha diminuído um
pouco e aos poucos ele foi se
organizando o seu veleiro com o mar
ele foi sincronizando a vela pra poder
ir pra onde ele achava que poderia ir
aos poucos ele foi saindo daquele lugar
os dois continuaram parados ali morreram
e saiu nesse campo
eu contei a história que a gente olhar
para o mundo hoje com essa visão
realista do que será que está
acontecendo de verdade no mundo né gente
pegar e olhar para a televisão você
acorda de manhã
li o jornal que você vai ver crime
corrupção violência terceira guerra
mundial só coisa ruim
aí você começa a achar que o mundo é
isso você começa a achar que não tem
saída que de fato canta tudo perdido
porque eu vou me esforçar porque tudo
perdido vai ter uma guerra daqui a pouco
e não adianta nada ou se sente fraco
impotente diante de tudo o que você vê
acontecendo
tem gente que está esperando que algum
incrível vai acontecer mas também não
está fazendo nada pra isso simplesmente
acontecendo e esperando e não vai dar
tudo certo porque tenho certeza que tem
uma nova era vindo aí mas que está
fazendo de verdade pra isso iria trazer
um olhar realista para isso é preciso
olhar em volta agora de vocês olha pode
olhar
o olho de quem está do seu lado e olha
para trás você tiver em casa
olha em volta na sua casa ou então pensa
nas pessoas tão perto de você pensa nos
seus familiares nos seus amigos nos seus
colegas de trabalho
quantas pessoas boas vocês conhecem
enquanto as pessoas ruins vocês vocês
conhecem
quantas pessoas que querem o bem da
humanidade querem o bem dos outros que
querem fazer bem
você conhece e quantas pessoas queriam
mal você conhece é muito provável que
você conheça muito mais gente boa e
gente ruim mas ainda assim a gente
continuar acreditando que tudo errado
por que será
a gente não está olhando o que está
acontecendo nos últimos anos eu comecei
uma busca por entender qual é o meu
lugar
uma busca pelo autoconhecimento e à
medida que eu entrava nessa busca eu ia
conhecendo pessoas também estavam nessa
busca entender o que significa sua vida
uma vida mais propósito e cada um
trabalhando em um movimento diferente né
de educação de empreendedorismo e dois
anos atrás escrevi um texto que eu
chamei de algo de grandioso acontecendo
no mundo
nesse texto tal como diria minha visão
de que eu vi que o mundo estava
instalando um lugar melhor pelo que eu
vi acontecendo por essas pessoas que eu
fui conhecendo então eu via que as
pessoas vão mudando o modelo do trabalho
as pessoas queixam porque o trabalho
nesse lugar mesmo eu quero ficar preso
no escritório que eu posso fazer para
trabalhar prova que eu gosto de verdade
como é que eu posso sair desse lugar com
que meu propósito aqui mas questionado
já começam a empreender mas também não
quer empreender só por empreender as
pessoas não querem mais ser o dono do
negócio não quero mais e posse
eu só quero viver a minha ideia só quero
criar aquilo que imagino é só
compartilhar e começa a colaborar a
gente começa a aprender como é que se
colabora para que tive em comunidade
novamente está começando a olhar pra
isso que cada vez mais pessoas
compartilhando carro compartilhado
apartamento compartilhando cada vez mais
coisas
essa economia é compartilhada surgindo
cada vez mais a gente vê as pessoas cada
vez mais fazendo a meditação tá fazendo
yoga buscando entender como é que esse
mundo invisível funciona esse mundo
sutil que a gente não consegue enxergar
mas que a gente tinha uma maneira sente
que
este mês vão se relacionar com essa
espiritualidade dessa forma a gente
começa a mudar a forma da gente se
alimentar
cada vez mais pessoas questionando por
que a gente vai tanto veneno começar a
colocar veneno na comida a gente não
falou nada porque a gente não questionou
se não se dava conta disso as pessoas
começaram a dar conta de controlar os
consomem e que não faz sentido consumir
desenfreadamente que muitas vezes o
consumo é preencher um vazio que eu
tenho e ela começa a perceber que ela
tem um vazio dentro dela e poder da
internet com a internet consegue
potencializar todos esses processos para
que a gente consiga descobrir novas
formas de se relacionar nossa mas
empreender novas formas de trabalhar
nova forma de viver
a gente está aqui por causa da internet
que vocês viram um evento na internet
está sentindo pela internet
agora eu estou aqui por causa da
internet a gente começou a aprender que
a internet tem um papel fundamental na
nossa evolução
mas a gente à nossa geração não cresceu
com a internet
depois está aprendendo agora o poder que
têm na internet escrever esse texto
joguei na internet dois anos atrás de
repente ele começou a se curtir e
compartilhado em algumas horas
ele foi lido por milhares de pessoas e
até hoje de dois anos pra cá foi lido
por quase 3 milhões de pessoas e foi
traduzido para nove idiomas
então escreveu um texto que dizia que
tinha algo de grandioso acontecendo no
mundo e isso foi compartilhado e lido
por três milhões de pessoas em nove
idiomas em homs que eu nem conhecia não
é que eu traduzia as pessoas vinham me
mandavam traduzido para a língua delas
então eu falei pode de fato então tem
alguma coisa de grandiosa acontecer no
mundo sim eu começo a acreditar cada vez
mais isso comecei a me movendo em
direção a se falar sobre isso fala
beleza então tá certo
eu olhei observem não era uma coisa
minha cabeça não era uma visão otimista
de que está tudo certo não houve eu
percebi a receber mensagens de pessoas
que diziam nossa eu achava que eu era um
e tenho a chave que só eu pensava nisso
mas eu tô vendo tem mais pessoas que
acredita na mesma coisa começa a confiar
o que está acontecendo agora e que isso
tem a ver com você tem algo de grandioso
acontecendo no mundo e gosto de falar
que ele está vivendo uma época muito
muito especial do planeta terra chamada
de era da verdade você pode chamar de
era de aquário é da informação nova era
de ouro tanto faz tanto faz o nome de
alguma coisa está acontecendo
um exemplo pra mostrar o que eu acredito
que está acontecendo
acho que a terra está passando por um
momento onde está recebendo muita luz
ele vai explicar em termos físicos
astronômicas astrológicos cada um buscar
a informação da forma como acredita mas
de alguma forma tenha alguma coisa
acontecendo e até a passar por um
momento de mais luz que isso significa
vou dar um exemplo é como se você
tivesse na sua casa ali o seu quarto tá
em um quartinho da bagunça
naquele quartinho que você joga todas as
coisas que você não sabe onde guardá la
você pegou e se desorganizou em uma
pelada se joga naquele quartinho aí você
tem algum lixo que você não quer levá lá
embaixo no prédio você joga naquele
quartinho e depois começa a jogar tudo
naquele quartinho escuro que não tem luz
fechado e você está sempre fazendo tudo
de forma automática você vai lá abre a
porta já a corrupção que é deixar a
festa vai viver sua vida
teve um dia que você foi lá abriu aquela
porta que não sentam naquele quarto
alguém acendeu a luz e você viu aquilo
que a nossa que é isso você viu quanta
sujeira você guardou você viu quanta
coisa você tinha inútil naquele quarto
você viu como estava suja você percebeu
coisa que você nem sabia porque estava
escuro que não via mas você fechou a
porta e foi tentar seguir sua vida só
que aquilo ficou incomodando ele porque
você viu que você percebeu aquilo que vi
que tinha muita coisa que fazer que não
estava legal que ele começa a se
incomodar você quer fingir que não está
acontecendo nada você continua sua vida
mas aqui ele está te chamando você não
consegue ignorar mais e você fala vou
ter que limpar porque também incomodando
eu vou ter que limpar aquilo e quando
você começa a mexer aqui vai trazer
muita coisa vai fazendo dores vai
trazendo lembranças memórias coisas que
você não sabia por que você guardou ali
mas vai trazendo o que está acontecendo
na terra agora chega num momento onde
está conseguindo ver agora coisa que a
gente não enxergava a gente tomou
consciência de coisa que a gente não
tinha consciência antes e uma vez que
toma consciência eu preciso fazer alguma
coisa eu não consegui ignorar mais
porque começa a incomodar e acredita que
a era na verdade é a possibilidade de
você resolver essas questões
por isso que hoje é tão difícil você
fica num trabalho que você não gosta
porque é tão difícil você a vida inteira
você para os últimos cinco dez anos
trabalhou no emprego você sempre se deu
bem lá tá tudo certo
de repente agora não consegue mais ficar
porque o que você viu que aquilo é pra
você que agora você sabe você tem
consciência de que aquilo não é pra você
tem que fazer alguma coisa por que é tão
difícil hoje ficar no relacionamento que
você não está feliz não dá mais para se
enganar
é o que chama de era na verdade não dá
mais pra enganar a gente é verdadeiro
a gente mesmo e apesar de parecer um
pouco assustador isso então não quer
dizer que eu tenha que pedir demissão e
pediu o divórcio e terminar seu
relacionamento mas você tem que olhar
você tem que falar sobre aquilo de
conversar com as pessoas no seu trabalho
você quer mudar a forma de trabalhar e
conversar com seu parceiro com sua
parceira para mostrar que você não está
feliz dessa forma que vocês vão poder
criar uma nova forma de se relacionar e
não aceitar as coisas como são
é como se tivesse chegado ao limite da
aceitação agora não dá mais para aceitar
as coisas como são
agora em fazer do jeito que a gente
acredita de verdade que a gente quer
viver aquilo que de fato faz sentido pra
mim essa é a nossa possibilidade
isso é muito incrível porque a gente tem
uma grande chance então cada um de vocês
agora tem uma grande chance de pela
primeira vez na vida começar a ser
verdadeiro com você porque o mundo está
dando possibilidades de você fazer
escolhas que você viver aquilo que você
quer que antes você não podia antes não
podia ver um programa que você queria
ver na hora que você queria ver você
liga a tv e você só podia ver aqui ele
estava pensando naquela hora você quer
que eu tô com essa espera a semana
seguinte o dia certo para você pode
assistir se quer ouvir uma música não é
a música que você quer
a música tocando no rádio naquela hora
hoje a internet mundo deu possibilidades
pra gente vai poder fazer aquilo que a
gente quer fazer da possibilidade para a
gente poder viver a nossa verdade posso
trabalhar naquilo que eu quero trabalhar
possa conhecer pessoas que acreditam na
mesma coisa que eu eu posso escolher
onde eu quero ir
eu quero escolher onde eu quero morar eu
posso escolher a gente não aprendeu a
escolher a gente viu nas palestras aqui
a gente aprendeu a obedecer a gente
aprendeu a seguir
a gente perdeu fazer o que os outros
diziam que deveria fazer
talvez lá atrás na sua vida em algum
momento você era uma pessoa muito
espontâneo uma criança espontânea que
tava lá no seu aniversário ganhou um
presente você achou que era um brinquedo
quando se abre não era um brinquedo a
roupa e você ficou chateado
cobrava ea sua mãe falou 'você tem que
ficar feliz tem que agradecer tem que
mostrar que você gostou e você aprendeu
a mentir
você aprendeu algo que você não pode ser
verdadeiro com você com você e nem com
os outros
só que hoje a gente não pode mais viver
dessa forma porque aquilo que incomoda
não só os outros mas incomoda muita
gente e nossa alma está gritando agora
para viver a nossa verdade a gente poder
viver aquilo que a gente acredita de
verdade pra mim essa grande chance que a
gente tem de se reconectar com as nossas
paixões de se reconectar com aquilo que
a gente gosta de fazer de verdade sabe
imagina como seria se você pudesse viver
por aquilo que você acredita que não só
você parece ver e ser remunerado
financeiramente por isso ganhar dinheiro
com isso
mas você tiver pessoas que apoiassem
naquilo que disse que estimulassem a ser
quem você é de verdade que tivessem
apoio que criasse uma rede de apoio pra
você pode ser quem você é você poder
viver a sua verdade a gente não sabe
fazer muito bem isso mas é o que está
começando a acontecer
observando sendo realista observando que
está consciente está aprendendo apoiar
uns aos outros criar a comunidade cria
tribo e de apoio colaboração e apoiado
mas é preciso que a gente não tá mais na
hora da competição que não é um contra o
outro
não vou garantir o meu se não ficar sem
não vamos juntos sozinhos é muito
difícil a gente chegou no limite da
nossa individualidade da competição da
separação e o que achava da verdade
trazendo é a grande verdade que nós não
estamos separados uns dos outros
nós temos grande parte desse mesmo todos
nós somos parte nós temos uma pequena
célula no planeta terra
a gente tem a nossa função aqui só que
para ficar tudo muito difícil e já
começar a se organizar
é o que está acontecendo estão aqui no
evento a gente está se reorganizando de
uma nova forma juntando as peças cada um
ocupando o seu lugar ea hora de cada um
para o seu lugar
eu penso que é como se nós fôssemos
parte de um grande quebra cabeça que tem
uma forma que tem uma estrutura que tem
uma figura que tem uma imagem que você é
uma pequena peça desse quebra cabeça e
você tem que ocupar o seu lugar
uma peça do quebra-cabeça fora de lugar
ela atrapalha
agora uma peça do quebra cabeça colocada
no neto ela dá referência para os demais
e quando você coloca a sua peça em seu
lugar quando você assumiu a sua posição
quando você entra no seu lugar
a vida começa a apoiar porque é um
momento propício para isso é que a terra
mais quer que você ocupe o seu lugar que
você faça aquilo que tem que fazer você
viva a sua verdade é que fechar seus
olhos por um por um instante se imaginar
como seria um mundo diferente você pode
fechar os olhos se quisesse não quiser
pode ficar com os olhos abertos também
ser livre sempre foi um fecho os olhos e
imagina como seria o mundo se cada
pessoa conseguisse viver pelas suas
habilidades de cada pessoa conseguisse
viver pelos seus talentos
outros grandes artistas a gente teria
talvez a mais bela música de todos os
tempos nunca foi escutada
talvez a mais bela obra de arte vai
começar a aparecer
imagina como seria se aquela pessoa que
gosta da natureza pudesse trabalhar na
natureza e imagina como seria aquela
pessoa que gosta de animais pudesse
cuidar dos animais
imagina como seria uma pessoa que gosta
de pessoas pudesse cuidar de pessoas
imagina como seria esse mundo que a
gente fosse viver
acredito que está passando por um
momento muito incrível a gente pode
chegar nesse lugar e é o que está
acontecendo como se fosse um grande
renascentismo agora uma possibilidade a
gente voltar a explorar nosso potencial
a desenvolver as nossas habilidades nas
nossas aptidões ver pela nossa paixão
quem quiser pode abrir os olhos agora
volta a gente está vivendo esse mundo
que você visualizou a gente tem que
acreditar
quanto mais a gente acredita mais
pessoas a gente tem achando que o mundo
é um lugar melhor
a gente muda o campo tem muita gente
achando que não é ruim não mudar vamos
inverter e trazer cada vez mais pessoas
a acreditar que de fato o mundo está
sendo um lugar melhor
o efeito disso é maravilhoso incrível e
da vontade de viver
é por isso que eu vim para poder ter
gosto e vontade de viver
paulo
[Aplausos]
[Música]